The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time, under the
tutelage of Professor Blendi,
you started to see some
of the consequences,
the more immediate consequences,
of some of the properties
we've been discussing
over the last few lectures
of binary liquid mixtures.
And in particular he
started showing you
some of the colligative
properties by which you
see changes in the vapor
pressure and the boiling point
and so forth, that arise because
you've got liquids in mixtures
and this affects their
chemical potentials.
And today I want
to start by going
through the fourth colligative
property that's commonly seen,
what called osmotic pressure.
And I mentioned this before.
Today we'll go through a
quantitative calculation
of its effects.
And then we'll start in on a
different unit of the course.
We'll start in on
statistical mechanics.
So let's continue with the
colligative properties.
And osmotic pressure plays a
super-important role, certainly
in all of biology, because of
course inside biological cells
you have solutions.
Water is in there,
along with a whole bunch
of other components.
And so the chemical
potential of the water
is strongly affected by
all the other constituents.
And this has profound
effects on what's
involved in maintaining an
equilibrium between what
goes on inside and
outside of the cell.
And this is the case
in all organisms.
And it's also
exploited of course
in all sorts of other contexts.
So what's happening with
osmotic pressure is,
you've got some
situation where there's
a semi-permeable membrane.
It allows one of
the constituents
but not others to pass through.
And typically that's water.
Although, of course,
it could be anything.
So, in the lab the way
this typically looks
is something like this.
Here's your
semi-permeable membrane.
Outside, we can
imagine that there's
pure liquid A. Could be water,
could be something else.
Inside, you've got
A mixed with B,
one or more other constituents.
And then there's some
level of the liquid
outside the container.
Of course, A can pass between,
pass through, the membrane.
And so what ends up
happening is, if you just
look at the situation,
what you immediately
notice is that
the liquid in here
goes up higher than
the liquid around it.
It's at a higher level.
It seems counterintuitive
at first.
And in fact it can
be enormously higher.
But that's what happens.
So there's extra height, h,
of liquid inside the container
relative to what's outside it.
And what that means is
the pressure inside here
must be higher, right?
Of course, the
weight of this liquid
is pushing down on
what's down here.
So the pressure
inside here is higher
than the pressure outside.
But of course, from
what you know already
about liquid mixtures, this
should in fact make sense.
Because what's happening
is that if these things are
at the same pressure, you know
that the chemical potential
of A is going to be
lower in the mixture.
It's always lower in the
mixture than it is in pure A.
So there's nothing to
stop A from rushing in.
So A does rush in.
If the liquid level goes up, it
raises the pressure down here.
But as the pressure rises,
now the chemical potential
changes and goes up.
So eventually, equilibrium
is reestablished.
Because these aren't
at the same pressure.
The additional pressure means
the chemical potential of A
goes up.
Of course, it goes down by
virtue of being in the mixture.
And those two things will
eventually reach an equilibrium
where the chemical
potential of A
is the same everywhere,
as it has to be.
So what we'll
calculate now is, OK,
how much does the
pressure go up.
When that happens.
So let's take a look.
And so of course, there
are all kinds of examples.
In a typical one,
A would be water.
And B would be one
or more sugars.
All sorts of other
potential constituents also.
OK, so let's just
consider the pressure
at two places that
are the same level.
The same height.
We'll label this
one point alpha.
Let's put some color in here.
We'll have points
alpha and beta.
And we'll make this distance l.
So now let's just
first calculate
what the pressure
is at both points.
It's going to be
higher here, because of
this additional liquid on top.
So, if we look at
point alpha, well,
let's start at point
beta, actually.
That's the simpler
one since it doesn't
have the additional liquid.
And first of all, there's
just atmospheric pressure.
So there's an external pressure.
Certainly, typically, it would
just be atmosphere pressure.
It's pushing down here.
It's also there.
So that has to factor in.
So there's our
external pressure.
And then there is the
product of this height
times the density
of the solution.
Times the gravitational
force constant.
And I'll work through
that momentarily
so you see that that
indeed is the pressure.
That's exerted by
the amount of liquid
that's up above this level.
But before I do that, let's put
the pressure at point alpha.
So p alpha.
And that's p external
plus l rho g.
But now, there's this additional
height on top of that.
So there's also h rho g.
There's an extra pressure.
We'll label this pi.
So we can write p alpha is
equals to p beta plus h rho g.
Which we'll say is
equal to p beta plus pi.
Now, just to make sure
we're all on the same page
about these quantities
being the pressure that's
exerted by the liquid,
let's just look at that.
So l times rho times g.
It should be a pressure which
is a force per unit area.
And in particular, this is going
to be a weight per unit area.
Remember the weight is the
force that a mass exerts.
And it exerts it because of
the gravitational constant.
So what happens?
Well, this is just a length.
Rho is a density, right?
So it's mass per unit volume.
And of course, g is just our
gravitational force constant.
So it'll be in units of
meters per second squared.
So what's going to happen?
If we multiply l
times rho together,
this is units of length.
This is units of volume.
What we're going to get
then is mass per unit area.
And that's what
it is, of course.
It's distributing across
the area of that surface
where point alpha is.
So these two
together, l times rho,
give us mass per unit area.
So it could be in
units of kilograms.
Per unit area, per
meters squared.
And now we're going to multiply
that by the gravitational force
constant.
So now we're going
to have all together
kilograms per meter
second squared.
In other words, it's
force per unit area.
And so that's what we have.
And now, of course, we have
the additional component.
Due to the height here.
Now, what do we know about
the chemical potential
in both parts?
The chemical potential
has to be equal
outside and inside
the container.
So mu A at point
alpha is just mu A
of the liquid at pressure p
plus pi and temperature T.
And that has to be equal
to mu A at point beta.
But point beta is just
in the pure liquid.
So that's just mu A
star of the liquid
at pressure p and
temperature T. So here's
the chemical potential
at point beta.
Here it is at point alpha.
Those two have to be
equal to each other.
And now we're just going
to use Raoult's law.
And what does that tell us?
We have RT log of xA plus mu A
star of the liquid at pressure
p plus pi and T So there
is our chemical potential
inside the container.
And that's equal to mu A star of
the pure liquid at point beta.
And so we can just
rewrite this as RT log xA.
Plus mu A star liquid
at pressure p plus pi
of T minus mu A star at
pressure p is equal to zero.
OK., now we need the
pressure dependence
of the chemical potential.
But we certainly have
an expression for that.
So we know that dG
is S dT plus V dp.
The temperature is the
same on both sides.
But we need to worry about what
happens at different pressures.
So at constant T, dG is V dp.
So now if we look at the
chemical potential, which
is just the Gibbs
free energy per mole,
then d mu A star is
VA star molar dp.
In other words, the difference
in the chemical potential
is, this changes as a
function of pressure.
Is going to be given by
the molar volume of a
under these conditions
in the pure liquid dp.
It's just the potential,
the pressure dependence
of G. It's not the kind of
topic I would have thought
would drive away
a lot of people.
But, you never know.
OK.
For the rest of you who are
willing to bear with me,
let's continue.
So now let's just integrate.
We need to know the change in mu
A at a finite jump in pressure
from inside to
outside the container.
So we're just
going to integrate.
So if I want mu A
star at pressure p
plus pi minus mu A
star at pressure p,
then I just have to integrate
from p to p plus pi VA bar star
dp.
And now I'm going to assume,
and this is certainly
a safe assumption, that this
quantity this, molar volume,
isn't going to change.
In other words, the
molar volume of liquid A
isn't going to
change significantly,
going from the pressure out
here to the pressure in here.
On the grand scale of things
it's a small pressure change.
We can assume that the
liquid is incompressible
over that small pressure change.
Which means that this
is constant, since all
we have then is simply
VA bar star times pi.
So then, substituting
back here, so now
we've calculated
this difference,
it's a simple result.
So then we simply have
that RT log xA plus VA bar
star pi is equal to zero.
Now, you saw last time,
and I'll work through this
quickly again,
that the log of xA
can be written approximately
as minus nB over nA
if you remember, this
came from writing
that this is equal to
the log of one minus xB.
But we're assuming that B is
the minor constituent here.
So xB is a small number.
So that this is roughly
equal to minus xB.
And that's just minus
nB over nA plus nB.
And since nB is much
smaller than nA,
this is approximately
equal to minus nB over nA.
So we're going to make
this substitution.
Also, this quantity,
this molar volume
of A over the pure liquid, since
the concentration of B is low,
we can assume that
this is just the molar
volume of A in general.
So, in other words, we
can write VA bar star.
We can just write it as VA bar.
That is, we're
not going to worry
about changes in
the molar volume,
either as a function of pressure
or a function of concentration
at the low concentrations
that we're working.
And then, note that
nA times VA per mole
is just the total volume.
Oops, not bar.
Not the molar quantity.
This is the molar
quantity multiplied
by the number of moles.
So it just gives us VA, the
total volume, occupied by A.
And using these two results,
then we have that RT times
negative nB over nA,
that's this result.
Plus VA over nA times pi is
equal to zero. nA will cancel.
And finally, since almost
all the volume is due to A,
again because B is
the minor constituent,
we can approximate further that
VA is approximately equal to V.
So finally getting rid of
the nA on the denominators,
we're left with a
simple expression.
pi times V is RT nB.
So we have a very
simple expression
which is called the
van't Hoff expression,
and look at how it
resembles the ideal gas law.
This is the pressure
times the volume equals
the number of moles times RT.
Of course, really it's
a change in pressure.
And this number of
moles is the number
of moles of a guest
constituent in a solution.
But it has the same form
that you're familiar with.
We also, sometimes it's
convenient to substitute,
since nB over V, that's
just the concentration.
That's the number of
moles over the volume.
And in that case,
the expression is
rewritten as pi is RT times c,
where it's understood that this
is the concentration
of the solute.
OK, any questions?
Let's work through
a numerical problem.
These things can seem a little
bit, they can seem simple,
but sometimes when
confronted with a problem,
sometimes it may seem less
than obvious what to do.
And also the results can
seem a little bit surprising.
So I just want to work through
a simple numerical example
to see how these play out.
So let's try, let's imagine we
have 10 grams of unknown solid.
Dissolved in 1000
grams of water.
The vapor pressure is
25.195 torr at 27 degrees C.
And the pure water vapor
pressure is 25.000.
No, .200 torr at the
same temperature.
So first, let's just
calculate the molecular weight
of the solid.
Now, this you I think,
saw from last time.
So this is straightforward.
It's going to come from
the vapor pressure lowering
not from the osmotic
pressure, which we'll do next.
So the delta p of H2O is
minus xB times p star of H2O.
Alright, this is from last time.
The expression for the
vapor pressure reduction.
Due to the concentration
of the mole fraction of B.
And then xB is 0.005
torr over 25.2 torr.
Right?
And that's 1.98 times
10 to the minus 4.
So that's our mole
fraction of B.
And then xB is nB
over nA plus nB.
So, now we have
this, it's 10 grams
divided by the molecular weight,
which is in grams per mole,
over 1000 grams of water.
Divided by 18 grams
per mole plus 10 grams
divided by the molecular
weight in grams per mole.
But since the solution
is overwhelmingly water,
we can get rid of this term
and make the math simple.
Can you see that?
I guess barely.
So this turns out to be about
1.98 time 10 to the minus 4.
And if we solve for
molecular weight,
then we wind up with
907 grams per mole.
So that's using one of
the colligative properties
that you saw last time.
Now let's, though,
finish up by calculating
the additional pressure
that we'll find.
So what's the osmotic
pressure of the solution.
So now we're going to assume
that we have that solution
inside, in a situation
like this where there's
pure water outside
that can go in.
And there's going to be
excess pressure because
of the water rushing
into the solution.
So what happens?
And let's use a
value of the density.
0.995 grams per
centimeters cubed.
So, pi is RT times c.
That's 0.08314 bar
per Kelvin mole.
Times 300 K times
c. c is nB over V.
So it's 10 grams divided
by 907 grams per mole,
over 1010 grams over 0.995
grams per milliliter,
I'm equating with
centimeter cubed.
And that turns out
to be 1.09 times 10
to the minus 5th
mole per millileter.
Let's get that into liters.
So we'll multiply by 1000
milliliters per liter.
So it's 1.09 times 10 to
the 5th moles per liter.
OK, yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
Oh, don't forget that, right.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, yes, yes, yes.
And I think that's the
case in the notes also.
Yep.
Thank you.
OK, so the concentration,
just to calibrate us here,
it's a pretty low
concentration, right?
It's about 10 to the
minus 5 moles per liter.
The excess pressure is 0.27 bar.
In other words, about a
quarter of an atmosphere.
Uh-oh, what's happening?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Where are we?
PROFESSOR: Sorry, where exactly?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
Yes, sorry.
Yeah.
10 to the minus 2
moles per liter.
All right.
And so the pressure that results
is a modest pressure, right?
It's about a quarter of an
atmosphere of excess pressure.
2.7 time 10 to the 4 pascals.
So let's just calculate, given
this small additional pressure,
how high is the
liquid going to go,
above the level of the solution.
Anybody want to guess?
You know, a centimeter.
10 centimeters.
100 centimeters?
Give me an order of magnitude.
Who guesses one centimeter?
You got three choices.
One, 10 and 100, and
you have to make one.
Who guesses one centimeter?
Who guesses 10 centimeters?
Who guesses 100 centimeters?
OK.
Now, fortunately we
don't do problem sets.
Or other scientific
problems by popular vote.
Rather, we just solve them.
Whenever possible.
So, what's the height
of a column of solution?
Well, that pi, remember, that's
equal to rho times g times h,
right?
And we know pi now.
So h is pi over rho times g.
So it's 2.7 times
10 to the 4 pascal
over rho, that's 0.995
grams per centimeters cubed.
Times 1 kilogram over 1000 grams
times 100 centimeters per meter
cubed.
I'm just getting
this into units that
will give me, that
will be in meters,
times 9.8 meter per
a second squared.
And when I multiply all
that out, it's 2.8 meters.
So that puny little pressure
ends up being meters high.
Taller than any of us, by far.
Sorry, it's up to there.
And that's actually
pretty typical.
And what that means is, it
actually makes osmotic pressure
a very, very sensitive
measurement method.
If you want to determine a
molecular weight, for example.
Because it's so
high, that means,
and of course you can measure
that height pretty accurately.
Certainly within
about a millimeter.
And so even relatively
modest concentrations,
it's still easy to see the
effect and measure the impact.
And use that to calculate
the properties of the solute.
OK, any questions?
Alright.
Now we're going to
start something new.
So, so far what you've seen,
and I hope come to appreciate,
is the whole structure
of thermodynamics
is built on empirical
macroscopic observation
and deduction.
We observe things.
We formulate these broad
thermodynamic laws.
All macroscopic.
It doesn't depend on any
microscopic model at all.
And in fact much of
it was formulated
before there was a good
microscopic model of matter.
Before the atomic theory
of matter, and molecules,
and so forth was
well worked out.
And it's incredible how powerful
that whole formalism is, right?
In some sense,
although it may seem
like neglecting what
we now know to be
an important part of nature,
actually part of its power
is its empiricism.
Right?
There are these
very small number
of fundamental laws from
which everything else follows.
And at this point,
of course, there's
just enormous confidence in
that small number of laws.
Because of their being
verified in so many context.
But, at the same
time, we do know
about the atomic
theory of matter.
We know there are
atoms and molecules.
So it ought to be possible,
at least in principle,
to start from a purely
microscopic approach to nature.
And just based on figuring out
the microscopic properties.
And then saying, well,
OK, my macroscopic stuff
is just a collection of
those microscopic entities.
I should also be able to figure
out macroscopic thermodynamics.
I should be able to start
from my microscopic picture
and get to macroscopic
thermodynamic results.
And in fact, that is possible.
And the theoretical
formulation for it
is what's called
statistical mechanics.
Called that because,
of course, you
won't be surprised
to learn that it's
going to require a
statistical treatment.
We're going to be dealing
with moles of material.
But now we're going
to be trying to think
about their
microscopic properties.
And so we'll be dealing not with
n number of moles, but with 10
to the 24th number of
molecules or atoms.
And you know we won't
be able to keep track
of every one of their
individual states, all the time.
We may be able to do a terrific
calculation of the quantum
mechanics or the
classical mechanics that
describe the states
that they could be in.
But there's no way in
practice that we're either
going to experimentally
or theoretically keep
track of all of that.
So we're going
to, at some point,
have to introduce statistics.
To take what we know about
the microscopic properties
and try to go from there
to the macroscopic results.
The thermodynamics
that we've seen so far.
And that's what statistical
mechanics is all about.
So let's try to
introduce a little bit
of statistical mechanics.
Where we're going
to go from what
we know about
microscopic properties
all the way to macroscopic
thermodynamics.
That's our objective.
So let's start by just
trying to calculate
energies of
individual molecules,
or individual particles.
And what's the probability
that some molecule, one
of the oxygen molecules
somewhere in this room,
is in a certain energy state.
Right?
And what our strategy
is going to be,
is to determine what are the
probabilities that molecules
are in certain states
with certain energies.
And if we can determine that
for all the possible states,
then we can average over those.
So without keeping track of
every individual molecule,
we could then calculate,
an average energy,
which is what you would
measure thermodynamically
when you look at the whole
collection and measure what
we call u, right?
Of course, we're
really averaging
over disparate energies
of lots of different atoms
or molecules.
They don't all have the
same molecular energy.
And we don't try to measure
their individual energies.
So that's what we'd
like to calculate.
And so we'd like
to be able to know
what are all these probabilities
of different energy states.
And then from
that, statistically
averaging, what are the
macroscopic average energies.
And other macroscopic
quantities.
So, let's start there.
Probability that a
molecule, must be specific
as possible is in
state i with energy Ei.
And right now we're
not even going
to specify the
nature of the state.
We could be worrying about
translational energy.
What state it is, how fast
it's whizzing around the room.
We could worry about its
vibrational or rotational
energy, or electronic state.
For now, let's not
even specify it.
Let's just say the
only thing we're really
specifying about
the state is it has
some energy that
we presumably know.
Now, what we'd like is
to know a functional
form for the probability.
And we don't know one a priori.
But let's just think
about two molecules.
And the probability
that one of them
has energy i, and another
one has energy Ej.
It also, let me say, would be
sufficient to think about even
one molecule and
say, we'll let's
think about independent
parts of its energy.
Let's say, translational
energy in this direction.
And in an orthogonal direction.
What matters is, we're thinking
about two independent energies.
Could be separate molecules
that aren't interacting.
Or independent degrees of
freedom on the same molecule.
But let's just consider it.
So a molecule is in state
i, and that another molecule
is in state j, with energy Ej.
So what we're going to calculate
is the joint probability
that the two molecules
are in those states.
So we want a probability.
This one, we'll call Pi(Ei).
This would be Pj of Ej.
And this probability together
will be Pij(Ei + Ej).
I could just write Ei comma
Ej, but the energy's add.
And that's crucial.
Now, since the molecules
are completely independent,
this should just be the product
of the separate probabilities.
Two completely
independent events,
or things whose probability
we want to determine together.
So, that suggests a really
simple functional form.
Because what we're saying here
is we want a function of a plus
b, which is equal to the same
sort of function of a times
the same sort of function of b.
In other words, when we
multiply these functions,
we get a function of the
sum of those arguments.
What functional form does that?
Exponential.
Sure.
So in other words,
e to the a plus
b power equals e to
the a times e to the b.
So it suggests that there's
an exponential probability.
Suggests it.
Now, there's also
some physical insight
that we can apply
to the problem.
First of all, we
expect that states
with higher energy
in general are
going to be less probable
than states with lower energy.
If it's cold, not much
thermal energy around,
and you say, how
much energy does
a particle in an equilibrium
collection of particles have,
at thermal equilibrium, if
there's not much thermal energy
around, you don't expect
it to be very likely
that a particle has a
huge amount of energy.
That one individual
particle has it.
Could happen, right?
From some random
collisions that just
happened to bulk up the
energy of that one particle.
But on a balance it's not
going to be very probable.
Lower energies will
be more probable.
And the other thing is, even
in thinking about something
like that, temperature comes in.
Immediately.
Right?
If you raise the
temperature a lot,
surely we have to expect
many more molecules will
start to become energized.
Will have more energy.
So, lower probability
for higher energy.
But the probability
of higher energy
should go up if the
temperature goes up.
In other words, the ratio
of energy to temperature
should be involved here.
So, P of Ei should go
down as Ei goes up.
And should depend
on Ei over T. Right?
So, we can start with
this functional form.
And by the way, there's
no reason we can't have,
in general we would have
some constants here, right?
We haven't changed
anything to do that.
And now let's just
use the little bit
of physical intuition that
we're thinking about here,
to refine this
just a little bit.
Let's write, we
expect that Pi of Ei
is some exponential to
the minus C Ei over T,
where C is some constant
greater than zero.
So this will have the property,
then, that as energy goes up,
the probability goes down.
But it's scaled by temperature.
If I raise the temperature, that
makes the higher energy states
get more and more likely.
Well, this is our
functional form
for probability of a
molecule being in a state
with energy Ei.
And the only difference
between this and what's
written conventionally is the
way the constant is labeled.
So really what we
have is Pi of Ei
is proportional to e to the
minus Ei over kB T, or just k
T, where kB is called
the Boltzmann constant.
And it's just equal to R
over Avogadro's number.
It's the gas constant per
molecule, rather than per mole.
One way to try to rationalize
this is, you've probably seen,
you've all seen Arrhenius
kinetics, right?
Arrhenius rate laws?
If you remember what
that looks like,
you get this rate constant.
Arrhenius rate constant
is some constant A times e
to the minus Ea over RT.
Remember that?
You've all seen that before?
And so what's
happening here, Ea is
what is an activation energy.
Remember, the idea
is that you've
got reactants and
products, and there's
some barrier you've
got to get over.
The activation energy,
before you can have reaction.
So the rate depends on
surmounting that activation
barrier.
This is really coming
from the same idea
as this, which is the
probability of one
of the molecules having
this much energy.
Depends on e to the
minus energy over RT.
This is per mole,
so this is per mole.
The exact same relation.
So the idea in the
context of kinetics
is that the rate depends on how
many molecules can get up here.
And what the probability is
of their getting enough energy
to go over the barrier.
And that energy,
that probability,
is given by this expression.
So in this form you've seen
this kind of dependence
before in a very explicit way.
Let me just take it one small
but important step farther.
Which is that
proportionality constant.
Couldn't we do better?
Couldn't we say, couldn't we
figure out what exactly it is,
not just what it's
proportional to?
Well, let's try.
So as we've written
it, we've got Pi of Ei
is proportional to e to
the minus Ei over kT.
We could write that as equals
A e to the minus Ei over kT.
This is just some
proportionality constant.
But we can determine
what that constant is,
because we know that if we sum
over all the possible states,
the molecule has to be
in some state, right?
So that sum of all those
probabilities has to equal one.
So sum over i of Pi of
Ei, is equal to one.
Because the molecule must
be in one of the states.
OK, now this is our expression
for all those p i's.
So let's just write that way.
a is just a constant times
the sum over all the i's of
e to the minus Ei over kT.
And so there it is. a is equal
to one over the sum over i, e
to the minus Ei over kT.
So now we can
rewrite Pi of Ei is
equal to e to the minus Ei
over kT over, the sum over i, e
to the minus Ei over kT.
Now, just so you're not
confused, this i matters.
That's the i we're
talking about.
What's the probability of it
being in some particular state
i with energy e i.
This i is just a dummy variable.
So just to be explicit,
we could write this just
as well as e to the
minus Ei over kT
times the sum over j, e
to the minus Ej over kT.
It could be confusing, but
this is usually the way
that it's written.
Even though this
dummy variable here
has nothing to do with
the particular choice
that's made here.
So now we know.
And we can calculate what the
probability is for a molecule
to be in any
particular state if we
know the energy of that state.
Now, notice we need to know
all the energies of all
the other states, too.
Because this thing,
in other words,
this a, right, depends on
summing over all of those.
But if we know those,
then we can do it.
We can do the whole calculation.
And for a good number of
cases, we realistically
do know it all.
So from the proportionality
relationship alone,
of course, we can tell
the ratio of chances
that you're in one
state or another.
Even without this a
constant, we already
could've said well, if
what's the ratio of,
the probability of being in
state i with energy Ei to state
j with energy Ej.
Well, it's just e to the
minus Ei over kT over e
to the minus Ej over kT.
It's e to the minus
Ei minus Ej over kT.
But apart from just being
able to get the ratio,
we can get the absolute number.
What's the absolute
probability that a molecule
is in any particular
state of a given energy.
Next time what
you'll see is what
can be calculated based on
the results that you've seen,
just the results
you've seen so far.
From these quantities
alone, it turns out
you'll be able to calculate
every single macroscopic
thermodynamic quantity.
So you'll see some
of that next time.